had an update now on the Prime
Minister's health this is from his
official spokesperson he said the Prime
Minister has been stable overnight and
remains in good spirits he is receiving
standard oxygen treatment within that
ICU unit and he has not required
mechanical ventilation or invasive
respiratory support and is breathing
without any other assistance we've also
been told that he has not been diagnosed
with pneumonia and the Prime Minister's
spokesperson said that he would update
us throughout the day as to the Prime
Minister's condition but some good news
that he is stable he remains in good
spirits and he's clearly not on a
ventilator he he has not required
mechanical ventilation I have some other
updates from that for you as well just
in terms of the running of the
government there was some confusion
perhaps last night as to what the first
secretary of state Dominic Robb was and
wasn't responsible for but it's been
made clear by the Prime Minister's
official spokesperson today that Dominic
Rob on security matters will step in as
necessary so if there's a security issue
it will fall to the secretary of state
to decide and this was what the Prime
Minister's official spokesman said he
said should a national security council
be required the Foreign Secretary will
chair it national Security's decisions
will be taken on the basis of collective
decision-making but the first secretary
of state there is Dominic Robb will
chair those meetings at some other
detail on the running of government
we're told that the Prime Minister
hasn't spoken to the foreign secretary
Dominic Robb today we were also told
that should mr. robb become unwell and I
should stress he's not unwell but should
he become unwell the chain of command
will move to the Chancellor rishis Cenac
Dominic Cummins the Prime Minister's
most senior advisor is still not in
number 10 but we're told that sir Mark
said well the man who runs Whitehall the
most
civil servant he is still working as
usual and then just finally in terms of
what comes next for all of ours on that
issue of the lockdown we know that the
three-week review is due on Monday the
prime minister spokesperson clear that
the focus remains still on flattening
the curve and we were given no update as
to when that decision will be taken no
legal requirement to renew the lockdown
on Monday but we should steer here in
the next few days about what the
government intends to do